california is in the lead can show the
rest of the nation how it is done
warning just coming in from cal iso who
runs the power grid in the state they
say they expect demand for electricity
to outpace supply tomorrow and they say
that means rolling blackouts are likely
yes
secretary granholm california is the in
the lead all right on well liberal
hypocrisy i can't get enough of that
sound bite because after the biden
energy secretary uttered those words
rolling blackouts sweeping across the
people's republic of california let's
bring in dave rubin host of the reuben
report and author of don't burn this
country hey man great to have you back
it's been a long time uh
gavin newsom just proposed a ban on the
sale of gas-powered cars by 2035. now
he's begging california's not to charge
their electric cars and turn off their
air conditioning because the power grid
just can't handle it then there's this
you gotta love the bee the babylon b
nailed it with energy grid unreliable
governor newsome announces all cars will
be wind up by 2035.
ouch what do you say dave
oh chris i mean first off as you know i
am an
ex-californian and i might remind the
newsmax people who do the chiron they
can always put ex-californian or proud
floridian under my name for now on uh
this doesn't surprise me this is exactly
why i and and quite literally hundreds
of thousands of other people have fled
california in the last two years as you
know california for the first time in
the state's history
had a net loss of population in 2020 and
then guess what it happened again in
2021 i myself took two businesses out
this is all obvious it is all obvious
nothing that progressives do by raising
taxes and giving more money to
bureaucrats accomplishes anything they
purport to believe in uh it was fairly
obvious that there were going to be
blackouts it's fairly obvious that the
homeless crisis will continue that the
drug stuff will continue that the
education system there will continue to
collapse etc etc but the people seem to
want more of it let's not forget chris
we're only a year off i believe it was a
year next week that that recall happened
and the recall was a massive win for
gavin newsom so the people are getting
exactly what they want and until enough
people either flee and the rest of us
just start ignoring california
altogether or
they actually rise up against this guy
this is just gonna continue but no one
should be surprised and by the way chris
you know he put out this video where he
was in you saw he's in that fleece right
so he's in his house he's obviously got
the ac blowing because he's in his
sweatshirt uh he's telling people to
keep their ac at 78. there is zero
chance that gavin newsom or nancy pelosi
or any of these clowns in california are
doing anything they are they are using
all of their electric utilities they're
doing all of their stuff and and staying
nice and
cool well and i too am a refugee from
the people's republic of california i
was born and raised in san diego i'll
never go back and a lot of people as you
state are leaving because of everything
you're they're talking about they're
number one in blackouts they're number
one in illegal aliens streaming across
the border they're number one in
taxation and high cost of living oh
great for the uh the business card uh
you know it's mind-blowing how fast
karma is catching up with people here's
congressman eric swalwell just two
months ago mocking my home state of
texas for its power grid issues quote
texas where republicans provide plenty
of energy to control your body but no
energy
to control your thermostat but here he
is yesterday quote it's time to rally
california we all need to do our part to
avoid power outages this week you know
rush limbaugh always said that hypocrisy
never attaches to leftists my question
to you dave is why
well look if it wasn't for double
standards they would have no standards i
believe that was ronald reagan uh this
is very consistent with these people you
know his his glib remark in the first
tweet uh on you know in essence he's
attacking texas for their feelings on
abortions well we have something called
states rights and the reversal of roe v
wade has now kicked this back to the
states and you don't have to stay in
texas if you don't want to and you don't
have to stay in california if you don't
want to but the hypocrisy it never ends
with these people eric swalwell has no
answers for any of this you do know that
he had his flatulence issue on msnbc so
maybe he could work on some wind power
uh over there that might help him in
northern cali but but look this is just
it's just what it is with these people
there is nothing that they do that works
i mean i really mean it i wish you said
you're from san diego i'm sure you have
great memories of san diego you don't
want it to be this way when i got to la
eight years ago it was not like this but
this is what it is and you've got to
vote out newsome you've got to vote out
garcetti uh you've got to vote out the
mayor of san francisco all they all from
top to bottom have to go and by the way
that doesn't necessarily solve it either
because you got to actually elect better
people
right and you've actually got to follow
the rule of law and follow the
constitution and that's again we could
go into a lot of problems with the
democrats out in california but the
national party reflects that as well i
want you to have a listen to democrat
jamie raskin he says that election
deniers are
fascists listen
two of the hallmarks of a fascist
political party are one they don't
accept the results of uh elections that
don't go their way and two they embrace
political violence and i think the court
has been thwarting formation of the
popular will the most spectacular
example being bush versus gore where the
majority by a 5-4 vote enjoying the
counting of more than a hundred thousand
ballots in florida and essentially gave
america its first court appointed
president uh i have an objection because
10 of the 29 electoral votes cast by
florida were cast by electors not
lawfully certified
[Music]
so jamie raskin on cbs over the weekend
says yeah they're all election deniers
they're fascists and they're political
violent people but he has been one of
the the cheerleaders for election denial
for for many many moons
it's a salsa show axiom democrats
project qualities onto others that they
themselves have in abundance am i right
well chris i often say that there's no
privilege in the united states other
than democrat privilege it's the
hypocrisy privilege that you're
referring to that they can do all of
these things they can be caught the next
day saying the reverse of what they said
the day before and it always happens
related to trump-related things of
course especially but all of the
election stuff let's not forget hillary
clinton she's still got the tweet up
that donald trump's an illegitimate
president uh all of these people who
were saying that donald trump was a
russian spy or installed by the russians
or our
elections were hacked or what's her name
stacey abrams in georgia who thinks
she's still she thinks she was the
governor from a couple years ago they
never end any of this stuff but what's
more interesting about it is is the
ramping up of the language because you
know for a long time okay we were all
bigots and racists and whatever then we
were nazis and trump is hitler now it's
all about fascism for these people and
of course the irony of that is fascism
is the combination in essence of the
state and giant corporations working
together to subvert the will of the
people does that sound more like the
republicans or the democrats it actually
is the democrat platform at this moment
so if you want to find a fascist raskin
i mean find a mirror man
amen to that dave mr man i'm glad you
made it back here we'll talk to you soon
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell